a russian submarine spotted sailing
towards the black sea as russia's naval
aircraft troops and military equipment
surround much of ukraine u.s president
joe biden spoke with ukraine president
vladimir zelinsky sunday working on a
diplomatic solution to the crisis
zielinski is telling his citizens not to
show russia any fear or panic the best
friend for enemies that is panic in our
country
but fears are growing that a russian
invasion could happen as soon as this
week the united states is prepared our
allies are prepared and now it's up to
russia to determine what the next step
they will take is
ukrainians have taken to the streets
urging peace but many expecting an
invasion of course i'm worried but am i
afraid not
the u.s is sending a total of 6 000
additional troops to eastern europe not
to enter a war but to defend nato
territory america and its nato partners
have repeatedly warned putin they will
shut russia off from billions of
international financial transactions
should russia invade the response in the
united states and our allies will be
swift
it will be united
it will be severe
but some experts believe putin is more
concerned about controlling ukraine once
part of the soviet union than punishing
economic sanctions
we think that putin's some kind of
rational actor calculating the
cost-benefit analysis of invasion when
in fact he's thinking about his place in
the history books 50 years from now
diplomatic staff members from the u.s
canada and other nations are evacuating
or relocating a growing list of
countries have told their citizens to
get out parishioners at this indiana
church are concerned for their pastor
who went to ukraine for a family funeral
i'm not going to
go to the worst case scenario but we are
worried about him and his family
over 100 000 russian troops are amassed
on ukraine's border while others train
for battle in belarus russian missiles
are also prepared to launch a buildup of
firepower that could strike on very
short notice
jennifer johnson global news washington